SPEAKER: It's my honor to
introduce Dr. Pascal Bokar
Thiam.
He's a professor at the
University of San Francisco
and the author of "From Timbuktu
to the Mississippi Delta:
How the West African
Standards of Aesthetics
Shaped the Music of
the Delta Blues."
He's also the owner
of the Savannah Jazz
Club in San Carlos.
So please give him a
warm welcome to Google.
[APPLAUSE]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM:
Thank you, Max.
I hope this is working.
And thank you for spending
a few minutes with me
and we're delighted
to be here at Google.
I was asked to come and
talk about this book
that I wrote a
couple of years ago.
And I wrote it because I
teach a course entitled Jazz
Culture and Social Justice.
And in the teaching
of this book,
I found out that
whenever we would
talk about American music
and this American art form
that we call jazz, all the
books talked about 1865 New
Orleans moving forward.
I was like, well, that's
really interesting because what
happens before 1865?
Well, what happens
before 1865 is documented
in the libraries or the
history departments of Harvard
University, in the
history departments of la
Sorbonne in Paris, or
in Oxford in England.
But somehow we never apply
that knowledge of history
to what it did and to what it
contributed to American music.
And so I was born in Paris,
and I thought I was French
and I found out that my father
was from a country named
Senegal and he was part
of the first generation
of West African who had
received a scholarship
to go study in Paris, which
is where he met my mother.
And we went back to
a city called Segou,
and Segou is in
the center of Mali.
And it's also the place which
is famous for the instrument
that you see behind me.
This is called a
kora in Malinke.
And kora by the way
means singing in Malinke.
And people interested
in etymology
will tell you that it's the
same word in Greek, which is
where the term kora comes from.
That instrument
is extremely old.
So I grew up in Mali and
I kept listening to music
coming from the United States.
And it was really
puzzling because I
was trying to figure
out how we got to this.
[MUSIC - BOBBY BYRD, "I KNOW YOU
GOT SOUL"]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: And I
was like, wow, this music was
making the entire planet dance.
And I was like, where
does it come from
and how do we get to that?
And I really couldn't find out
except that my dad said, well,
you know, Africans were
taken to the United States.
I was a little kid.
I said, Africans were
taken to the United States?
I'd say, why?
And he said, well, when
you get a little older,
you'll study it.
I was, huh, interesting.
So in the process
of my studies, as I
was looking at the
demographics and I
was looking at the history, I'm
looking at the United States,
a majority population
of European descent,
African-American
represented about 10%
of their population, the largest
ethnic group in the United
States being of
German descent, which
is why the country as a whole is
Baptist from the Martin Luther
school.
I was like--
I ended up studying classical
music in a French conservatory.
So it was very
academic and they know
exactly how the music works.
The oldest recorded
music in Europe
is what we call
the Baroque music.
And I was listening--
[MUSIC - BOBBY BYRD, "I KNOW YOU
GOT SOUL"]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM:
--and I was like,
that cannot possibly translate.
This cannot possibly
come from this.
[MUSIC - CLAUDE DEBUSSY, "THE
FOUR SEASONS CONCERTO NO.
1 IN E MAJOR"]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: So
where does music come from?
What are the foundation
of this music?
Where are its roots?
And how come I can't
find it in the books?
And so I looked around, then
I studied a little bit more,
and I found out that this is
that between 1515 and 1888,
we brought in to the southern
part of the United States,
between North and
South Carolina,
Alabama and
Mississippi, Louisiana,
in excess of 8
million West Africans.
West Africans.
99% of African-Americans,
I found out,
are from the west
part of the continent.
They're not from the north,
they're not from the east,
they're not from the south.
They come out of the west.
If you go to St.
Augustine, Florida,
there is a plaque that says,
first Africans arrived.
It say 1550.
Was recorded by the Spaniards.
And the Spaniards acknowledged
that the French were there
with Africans before them.
1860 is when the US
government sends back--
is recorded as
sending back a ship
called the Clotilde
in Mobile, Alabama.
That's a first archive of
the US government taking.
And I started thinking
because I was--
I was a developing musician.
I wanted to-- I was really
interested in learning
to play jazz, and I was amazed
by the complexity of that art
form.
Jazz was very complex.
My dad used to play those
records all the time,
and I really didn't
like them very much.
I like James Brown.
By the way, the
gentleman that you
heard before that was
singing, I got soul,
I know you got soul,
that's Bobby Byrd.
He's the one who
discovered James Brown.
And James Brown was in his band
as a vocalist and a keyboard
player.
And I found out that
the concentration
of Africans in the southern
colonies in some cases
was four to one.
It was a majority population.
1515 to 1888,
that's a long time.
West Africans come every
day, every week, every month,
of every year.
It is not as if they just
came and then, and stop.
No, no, no, no.
They kept coming.
And they kept coming with
their songs, with their music,
with their instruments, with
their sense of religion.
If you go to Louisiana in some
parts when it's really dark,
they talk about voodoo.
Be careful.
Voodoo religion exists in
Ghana, in Togo, in Benin.
And so I found out that
the greatest concentration
of Africans was actually
in the Mississippi Delta.
And in the Mississippi Delta
emanates a popular form
that at the beginning
of the 20th century
we're going to call
the Delta blues.
And I started to
listen to a gentleman
by the name of Son House.
And if you're interested in the
roots and the origin of blues,
you have to go to Son House.
S-O-N H-O-U-S-E. He is a
giant in that art form.
And what I was
listening to this--
[MUSIC - SON HOUSE, "COUNTY FARM
BLUES"]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM:
And I said, wow.
I listened to that I said,
that's the music of the Delta.
And when I heard that,
I knew it had nothing
to do with baroque music.
It sounded a lot like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: That's the
music I was hearing at night.
And I realized in the
course of my studies
that there are three medieval
empires that are recorded
in the West, in West Africa.
One of them, the first
one is the Empire
of Ghana, which is roughly
from the fourth, fifth century
until the 10th century.
And I was talking to
some of my colleagues,
and if you look at it,
it's placed right there.
The north is part of Senegal.
It's called the Empire of Ghana.
And it has nothing to do with
the country of Ghana, which
is a lot further south.
But where there was
a direct relationship
with the country of
Ghana is that Ghana
was a British colony.
It was the empire
of the Ashantis.
The British were there.
They called it the Gold Coast.
And Kwame Nkrumah, who was a
revolutionary and a scholar,
wanted to name
his country, which
was one is the first
independent countries
of the African continent, after
the first recorded medieval
empire of West Africa.
And that's how the country
got its name, Ghana.
But the Empire of Ghana
itself was a lot further
north than the country of Ghana.
The second empire
that comes in is
the Empire of Mali from the 10th
century to the 14th century.
And you can see how
extended it goes.
And it controls the trade
routes to all of Europe
to the Middle East to Asia.
And at some point,
Mali is a gold reserve
of the Western world.
It's well documented
that those trade
routes are very well managed,
very well administered.
And you have to have
in place societies
would know how to do this in
order to have successful trade.
And the third Empire I found
out was the Empire of Songhai
from the 14th to
the 17th century.
And it takes-- it grows
concentric from that.
And that's probably the
largest West African empire
that we had.
So what that told me-- and if
you look there is a river here,
which takes its roots in
Guinea that goes all the way up
north to Muktu, which is
a real city by the way,
and all the way down to
the delta of Nigeria.
That's how big that river is.
It's the third largest
river in the world.
And it gives it's
name to two countries.
There's a country of
Niger here, the country
of Nigeria right there.
And the riverways
are the place where
people exchange cultural norms,
exchange languages, exchange
skills, exchange technology,
instrument, music, songs,
lullabies.
It is-- it serves the same
cultural and economic process
as the Mississippi, Missouri
River, from the Gulf of Mexico
all the way into
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
St. Paul, where it
takes its roots.
So very important
riverways managed
these empires had
some navies of sort
to ensure that the
commerce would prosper,
and so forth and so on.
So I started thinking.
I said, well, if they
could manage trade routes
that successfully--
and by the way,
this is a time where
there is no inbalance
between the African
continent and Europe
because there is no recorded
history of European empires
trying to go into Africa.
They're not, which
tells you that there's
a lot of respect between
the kingdoms of Europe
and the kingdoms of Africa.
They trade, and that
commerce is well-documented.
But with the event
of the gunpowder,
we are going to start seeing
a shift in these relationships
as a result.
But I started thinking.
I said, OK, so the trade,
the Atlantic slave trade
takes place, you
know, around 1550
with the Spanish and
the Portuguese first,
and then the French and the
British and the Dutch later.
And then these
European powers vie--
they battle each other
for control of that.
But I said, these populations
come with knowledge,
with music, with technology.
By the way, there's no
rice in the United States
before the arrival
of West Africans.
So much so that plantation
owners were looking for people
from the West part between
Guinea, Senegal, and Gambia
who knew how to cultivate rice.
And at one point
before the Civil War,
rice is the main economy
in the Carolinas.
If you look at the foods of
the South of the United States,
whether you go to New Orleans,
okra, which you need for gumbo,
comes out of West Africa.
Black eyed peas, West Africa.
So you have an entire
culture, and the food
that people eat in the
South are the same food
that people eat in West Africa.
Because you don't move
millions of people
over long periods of time
without bringing them
with their culture.
And so I started thinking,
OK, in American music, what
is the oldest American
musical instrument?
And people started
telling me, well,
in my classes I have some smart
alecks who would say, you know,
the voice, which is true.
And then I hear the
drums, which is also true.
I said, but, I said Native
Americans were here first.
Their culture has not got
into the mainstream of America
because none of you can sing me
a Navajo lullaby, for example.
It hasn't transferred into.
But America's oldest musical
instrument is called the banjo.
But there's not a
single banjo in England.
There's no banjo in Ireland.
There's no banjo in Scotland.
The banjo comes
out of West Africa.
It comes out of Mali.
It is the instrument
of the people.
It's easy to make.
It's easy to tune because
there's only about
three strings mostly.
Afterward we added
some extra strings.
But it is the instrument
of the people.
And it's a very, very
important instrument
because that instrument allowed
the West African population
to reorganize a sense
of cultural identity
in the face of these
political economic hurricane
that they encountered
coming into the South
and into these plantations.
And so I'm going to take you
to a place near Segou, which
is a place where I grew
up, so that you can hear--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
This is [INAUDIBLE].
I was born here.
[INAUDIBLE] is part
of [INAUDIBLE]..
[INAUDIBLE] is made
up of 12 villages that
exist since the 13th century.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's a ngoni.
In the 13th century,
only the great warriors
were allowed to listen to it.
The ngoni is Mali's
oldest string instrument.
The djinn, the water spirits
that live in the Niger,
gave the ngoni to my
great grandfather.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I was about 20 years
old, I went to [INAUDIBLE]..
That was in '84.
I met [? Toumani ?] in '87 and
we started working together.
I played my first concert
in Europe with him
at a festival
called [INAUDIBLE]..
Then I traveled to the USA
alone to represent the ngoni
at the Banjo Folk
Festival there.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The banjo has its origins here.
In the US I went
to a banjo museum.
There I saw that the slaves
that were brought from Africa
built the instruments just the
way we used to build them here.
We used to make them
with our calabash.
The blacks that were brought
to the US did the same thing.
Later they added a lot of
machines to their banjo.
We here in Africa
didn't change much.
We left it like it was.
But still, it's the same thing.
The banjo and the
ngoni are the same.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
That's what A banjo
sounds like, isn't it?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM:
When I started
thinking about the banjo--
because, you know, I'm
a guitar player and I
like all forms of
music that where
a guitar is very present--
and country music has a lot
of great guitar players.
And they also have
a lot of banjo.
And I started looking and I
was like, how did that happen?
Well, in order to
understand how that works,
we have to understand the
chronology of the demographics
in the United States.
So West Africans bring the
banjo in the plantations
of the South.
And West Africans are
also in the plantation
in charge of the music.
And for the longest time, they
are going to play the banjo.
When European-Americans move
into the United States between,
literally between 1790
and 1840, the first wave,
the second wave is between
1850 and 1910, they find--
these European populations were
coming from the British Isles
in particular--
find on the banks
of the Tennessee
River these African
populations have been there
for several hundred
years before and play
that instrument, the
banjo, with these colors
that we are later at the
beginning of the 20th century
going to call the blues.
The term blues is something that
the industry with the invention
of the phonograph gave
to black people's music
so they could sell it.
These Irish populations,
Scottish populations
find these African populations
and they like what they hear.
They're going to
integrate the sound--
first of all the banjo,
but also the sound
that the colors of
the music of the Delta
into their own Celtic
heritage to give birth
to another American
form of music,
which is extremely popular
outside of the coast,
called Bluegrass.
And you did that
instrument for Mali
in order to have good Bluegrass.
Otherwise, you might have
something and it would be nice,
but that wouldn't be Bluegrass.
You need that instrument.
The banjo is even more
important in terms of aesthetics
because the rhythmic
syncopation of the banjo.
You know, when it goes
like [RHYTHM] like this.
That's what Africans
are going to translate
when the missionaries
in the 1650s
brings them Christianity
and the piano.
The syncopation of
the banjo are going
to be translated on the
left hand of the piano
to give America a new form of
music that we call ragtime.
So it's interesting to see
how the transfer of standard
of aesthetics in
music have applied,
and over time have developed
into the United States
several forms of music who
have identity markers that
gives this nation its own
sense of cultural significance.
But it comes from this
marriage over time
of this West African
culture, which
you hear later on in the music
of Bobby Byrd or James Brown
or Buddy Waters or
Louis Armstrong.
And so I started thinking,
because growing up in Africa,
I found out that Americans
are the only people
on the face of the planet
who clap on two and four.
And what I mean by that,
when you listen to music,
you're listening for--
it's called a norm--
you're listening for that space
where you're supposed to clap.
And sometimes, you're
not in the right spot,
and you rectify real
quick, because you
don't want your friends
to think you're square.
And it's not intuitive.
It's something that
you have to learn.
It's part of culture.
So if you grow up in
the Baptist church,
and you hear everybody
clapping, you're like, OK,
this is where it is.
But if you don't grow up
in the Baptist church,
everybody might be on that beat,
and you're on the other one.
And I said, why
are they beating--
because Europeans use one
as their metric reference
of rhythm.
So Europeans clap on one.
Africans also couple on
one, for different reasons.
So why are
African-Americans, who
started clapping on two
and four, not on one?
So the reason for that is
because I found out that when
these Africans came here and
they started beating on that
wood-- which is where
the term rap comes from--
things would happen.
You know, the stopwatch
would catch fire,
so everyone would run away.
Somebody get poisoned.
So very quickly
in North America,
in the plantations of the
South, plantation owners
took the drums away from them.
That's why in American music--
unlike South American music
or Central American music--
it's very hard to hear even
the sounds of percussion.
I think we only hear in
mainstream American music
the sound of percussion
around the '60s when there
is a resurgence of a
national sense of pride
with respect to Africa
in the music of Motown.
I think Marvin Gaye we
hear some percussion.
I think in the music
of Donnie Hathaway
we hear some percussions.
But very quickly after the
'70s, and certainly by the time
of the '80s, that ethnicity
of sound is relegated to--
is taken over by the computer
and by the synthesizer.
So in my studies, I started
looking, and I said,
there's got to be a
fundamental reason why
Americans as a whole--
why African-Americans
drove an entire nation
to clap on two and four.
Because when I would take
Africans to a jazz club,
and they would listen to that
double base going [RHYTHM]
and African-Americans
would be [RHYTHM]
And then they would look
at the African over here,
and the African-Americans
would look
at these African
populations and say,
why are they on the wrong beat?
Well, we know they have
rhythm, so that can't be it.
Well, what happens is that
when Africans are listening
to sound, the
subdivision of time
is always ternary, meaning that
they're subdivided by three.
So when they're hearing
the bass going [RHYTHM],,
they're actually
hearing [RHYTHM]..
That's what they're hearing.
Which is where that notion
of swing comes from.
Ellington said, it
don't mean a thing
if you ain't got that swing.
And that's what
he's referring to.
And I started looking at
the West African rhythms
in general, and particularly
the rhythms of Mali.
And 99% of the West
African rhythms
are sequentially created.
Technically they call
that poly-rhythm.
But they really are sequences.
And what happens is that when
you listen to this rhythm--
and we are going to do a
little exercise together--
you can hear-- these rhythms
go like this [RHYTHM]..
And if you put that
in the context of four
beats per measure, which is what
the missionaries in 1650, 1660
brought to Africans
in the plantations,
and you're starting
to do [RHYTHM]..
So you're going to do--
do this with me.
One, two, three, four,
one, two, three, four.
So keep doing it.
Three, four.
[RHYTHM]
And you're going to
hear that the accents--
[RHYTHM]---- end up
on two and four.
[RHYTHM]
So now the pulse becomes a
reference point, as opposed
to the one.
Africans are hearing [RHYTHM]
and they're thinking [RHYTHM]..
And so West Africans were
stripped of their percussion.
They were stripped
of the instrument.
But they never lost a pulse.
And so any music that
was given to them,
they re-inserted
that pulse there.
So much so that when
the missionaries bring
Christianity, and
they're singing
the hymns of the old
Church of England,
the Africans are
listening to the way
these Europeans are singing,
and they say OK, we're
spiritual by nature.
We will embrace Christianity.
And we'll sing these songs.
But we're not going to
sing them like that.
That's that not our expression.
We're going to sing it this way.
And the way Africans express
their music was so shockingly
different from what
European experience was
that the same hymns that they
were singing at First Baptist,
they called that
negro spirituals.
And that right there
gives you a sense
that these populations
from West Africa
were bringing that
sense of expression
and a sense of delivery and a
rhythmic impetus and necessity
which was so important to
their old sense of identity
that it was reflected in
any music that they touched.
And so when you look
at American music,
and when I was listening
to Bobby Byrd--
and this was labeled
American music--
I was like, yeah, it's
uniquely American.
Sure.
But the aesthetics that
fed that foundation
could only have come
from the Western part
of the continent of Africa.
And these rhythmic markers,
which are accompanied
by these colors of the blues--
which by the way, the church--
in particular, the
Catholic church
was going to label notes of the
devil, and things not to play.
These colors made me realize
that music is an expression
of cultural power.
And it's really important
to understand that.
And as such, it is extremely
difficult in the context
of a majority population to
accept that it is its minority
population--
i.e.
African-Americans-- who gave
the majority population the art
form for which it is
known all over the world--
i.e. jazz.
It was jazz that was born
at the roots of the delta,
into blues, into the
music of Al Strong,
into the music of Ellington,
into the music of Dizzy
Gillespie and Charlie Parker
and to the music of Miles Davis.
And the context for this was
always a political context.
It is Europeans--
European scholars--
who told Americans,
stop playing classical music.
You have an art
form of your own.
You have to go to the
other side of the tracks.
Because we studied.
Europeans had the benefit
of being more expansive
and being an older civilization.
You have people like
Ravel and Debussy,
who are scholars in music.
They study this music
coming out of the South,
and they're like, whoa.
They write it down.
They see the complexity of the
work of Ellington and Strayhorn
and King Oliver and Armstrong,
that they start saying,
there is something
going on here.
So much so that
Europeans as a whole
stopped playing their music.
And little kids-- particularly
the British kids--
are going to go and study
this music of the South,
the music of the delta.
And thus are born the Beatles
and the Rolling Stones and Led
Zeppelin.
And even the bands
from England who
dealt with the
history of the blues
and this idea of modern sounds.
There's a band
called Pink Floyd.
Did you know that Pink
Floyd was a cult name that
would tell band members whether
or not you were experienced?
Pink Floyd is named after
two great rural blues
singers of the
American South, one
named Pink Anderson and the
other named Floyd Council.
So Europeans are so taken
by this music coming out
of the other side
of the Atlantic
that all of a
sudden, they forget
about the music of Handel.
They forget about the
music of Beethoven.
They delve into American music,
into the roots of this music
coming from the South.
And that's why we got to this.
Now, I want to play
for you that instrument
called the ngoni in a
contemporary setting
in West Africa.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you listen to
this music carefully,
you can hear the
swing of a jazz band.
[RHYTHM]
That pulse is what gave American
music its unique marker.
And that pulse is
what Africans never
lost in the evolutionary process
of their journey in America.
Now, some people
say, do you have
to be Africans to
have that pulse?
So let me tell you something.
In Senegal, we have
European Americans
who have been there for
several generations.
And there's these two little
blonde kids in my neighborhood
who had never been to France.
They grew up with us.
They heard those percussions.
They heard those pulses.
And they would go to the
traditional dance parties
and they would
dance just like us.
And French people coming from
France would look at them
and say, how come they
can dance like this?
So really, it's more
culture than nature.
It's really important
to understand that.
Why?
Because I believe that we
haven't studied enough what
happens to the developmental
brain of a child
in his mother's womb.
If you live in Africa and
you hear these percussions
and you hear these
pulses for nine months
before you come
out, when you come
out regardless of your racial
makeup, you're swinging.
You are swinging.
Because it's ingrained.
It has become part of you.
So that's my talk for today.
I want to leave some
time, because if you
have some questions, I'd
be happy to answer them.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So earlier
on you showed a clip
where the gentleman
was playing--
I can't remember the name of
the instrument, the guitar.
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: Ngoni.
AUDIENCE: Ngoni, yeah.
It is like a banjo.
And you or him was mentioning
that this was an instrument
given to the warriors.
So I'm wondering--
I play guitar in classic
rock music, Led Zeppelin,
that kind of era stuff, right?
And of course, the guitar is
often referred to as an axe.
I'm wondering if
in your research
you came across the etymology
of that use of the word axe
for guitar, and if there's
any kind of correlation,
relationship between
these warriors having
this axe-like instrument.
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: It's a
really interesting question.
You know, it's interesting
you're saying that,
because at the club,
we have jam sessions
on Mondays and Wednesdays.
And at the jam session, when
the guys bring their instrument,
I greet them at the door.
I say, I see you've
brought your weapon.
So yeah, I think
you definitely can
think about it as an element of
representation of your power.
Because an instrument
does nothing.
It is what you do with it.
I mean, everybody plays
guitar, but guitar players
are not the same.
For example, the trumpet-- the
trumpet is a German instrument.
But after Louis
Armstrong played it,
everybody wanted
to play like that.
It became an
American instrument.
So what you do with the
instrument is really--
this is what shocked Europeans.
The piano, a
European instrument.
But after they heard Art
Tatum, they said oh my god,
what's going on over
there in that country?
It became the standard.
So what humans break--
it is the shear force
of their spiritual power
that makes that
instrument speak.
And that's really
what's important.
And that's why music speaks
to our common humanity
well beyond race.
And the reason why
I'm saying this
is because what I found out.
And I tell that to my students.
You're only concerned about
race because you can see.
And in my journey,
in my travels,
I truly believe
that race is a trick
that God put on humans to
see if they've developed
the intelligence of the heart.
Because music allows you
to speak beyond vision,
because you're dealing
with sound wave vibration.
And those are expressions
of your inner.
And your inner is not a
function of your skin tone.
That doesn't that
race is not important.
Race is important,
because it defines
your social cultural
experiences.
But it's just one
step out of it.
I don't know if I
answered the question.
AUDIENCE: That was
very [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: I think it's
really fascinating
the way you talked about almost
an evolutionary model of music,
the way different forms of music
are hybridizing with each other
and creating new forms, which
are then being mixed and picked
up by other people in
different countries
and then brought back.
Is this something--
I mean, you've
talked a lot about tracking that
over the last couple hundred
years.
But is that something
you think is
sort of fundamental to music,
that it has that life to it?
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: Yeah,
it's a very complex question
that you ask.
And I'm glad you asked it.
It's hard to answer
it quickly, but let
me try to come to it this way.
What I described in this short
presentation and in my book
is essentially the history and
the social cultural journey
of a people over time.
In the case of American
music, I looked at the history
of the African diaspora.
That knowledge is
extremely important,
because when I look at
the history books today,
there is no reference to the
contributions of the West part
of the African Continent.
And yet it is so present in
our mainstream every day.
Just the fact that you guys
are doing that tells me you're
African.
You just don't know why
or how come, but you are.
The fact that you play in
major tells me you're African.
You don't know why, but you are.
The fact that you're using
those sounds in the blues
tells me you're African.
Regardless of your
skin tone, it tells me
that you are Americans,
and therefore
that you've had that
African influence.
Where it becomes tragic is
for young African-Americans--
particularly boys--
who get it to their teenage
years, and they rebel
against the system,
to have not been
given the benefit of knowing
that they actually come--
that slavery is a
bump on the journey
of the nations of Africa.
It is not the beginning.
And most young
African-American kids
are not taught
about these empires
of Ghana, the empire of
Mali, the empire of Somalia,
who've delineated the
standards of aesthetics.
So when they look back, all they
see is slavery and a system.
If they had the
chance to be given
a sense of chronological
history within a context that
is academically sound, then
that would give them the tools
to say OK, life is hard here.
But you know what?
I come from great people.
There's an entire
continent behind me
that contributed great stuff.
And look what we did here
in America musically.
I mean, you go to Singapore,
they have a jazz festival.
I go to Scandinavia, they
have a jazz festival.
You go to-- that comes
out of that community.
Giving them that sense
of historical perspective
and chronology would go
a long way to giving them
the tools to move forward in
life and say, yeah it's hard.
It was harder for others.
But we come from great stuff.
We can overcome.
We can contribute, and we
want to contribute positively.
And so knowing where you
come from essentially
gives you the confidence
to overcome the obstacles
that you're going to find
being a minority in a majority
population.
Because one of
the things that we
need to understand very
clearly about the friction
in the United
States, the friction
is black and white
because that's
the nature of the society.
But if you look at Europe,
they have minorities who
have contributed enormously.
For example in classical music,
every major classical musician,
whether it's Mozart or
whether it's Beethoven,
have said we've got our
ideas of the Gypsies.
Musically, we would
go to Gypsy camps
to hear how they
played the violin,
and we would hear
those melodies,
and we're re-arrange them.
It's not black and
white over there.
They are all white.
The Gypsies are maybe
a little darker.
But you know what I mean?
So it's frictions of minority
versus majority populations,
and you have those frictions
irrespective of skin tones.
And it's really something
that's important to understand,
because a lot of people tend
to get lost in the race issue.
And the race is an issue.
But the social construct and
the friction of societies
has to be understood
beyond that.
And the music tells you
things about societies
that the music books want.
Say that when you
hear an American white
playing the banjo, if you have
knowledge, you're like wow,
this is how that
instrument from Mali
came into his own expression.
And understanding that and
having that perspective
is what allows you to overcome
social cultural realities that
are very relevant.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this music
guy is a cultural superstar.
And then one other
thing is when you
talked about what was happening
in the European music,
I used to sneak up and sit
in your classes unregistered,
because I was there
for the knowledge.
And you introduced us to one
of the Three Musketeers, who
was a great musician.
Can you talk to us, I think it
kind of balances in with what
you're saying in terms of race.
When they asked John Coltrane,
does race have anything?
And he says, no, race has
nothing to do with it.
There are people that are not
of the African race that'll
look to this music,
and they'll enjoy it,
and they'll want to be a
part of it, and some of them
will contribute.
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: These
are difficult questions,
but you should know that
this is the Archbishop
of the Church of St.
John Coltrane was here
in the audience.
So I want to--
let me say this.
What I have said is that
African-Americans created
an art form in the
United States that
lifted this nation to the
status of a cultural superpower.
And we see that crystallization
of reality in the period
that we call the
Harlem Renaissance.
This is a time where--
prior to the Harlem
Renaissance, America
was looking to Europe for a
high standard of aesthetics.
People were trying to dance
the way Europeans danced.
People were trying to
play music the way--
after the Harlem
Renaissance, after Al Strong,
after Ellington, after Lindy
Hop, all of that was gone.
Americans have found a sense of
identity within their culture
through this art form.
And Europeans may choose
to dance this way,
but now Lindy Hop is
the way Americans dance.
And you guys are young here, but
you guys think you can dance.
You cannot dance.
Go see your grandparents.
They were dancing at a time when
they didn't have health care.
And when you see what they
were doing with Lindy Hop,
it's amazing.
In tempo rhythm, people
actually play instruments.
Not computers doing beats.
And that's why I was saying
after the Harlem Renaissance,
Europe looks to the United
States for direction in music,
in the way in which
we organize music,
in the structure of composition.
And that's why I
tell my students,
if you don't get an A in
the jazz history course,
we cannot give you a passport
to get out of the country.
Because you go to
Europe, and they
know more about
Ellington and Strayhorn
and Benny Goodman and
Grant Miller than anybody
I can actually quiz
somewhere on your campus.
I can tell you that.
That's how important
that art form became,
not just to the United States--
because we're the one who
actually look at it the least--
but elsewhere.
Because they realized--
when you're a trumpet player
and you hear Armstrong, and
you pick up that instrument
and you try to play, you realize
that the gap between your skill
set and his is the size
of the Grand Canyon.
And everybody wants
to get over there.
And that's why this art form
is so important to this nation.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned
that there isn't a lot of books
that talk about this history.
And I was just
curious if you had
pointers besides your
book of other places.
PASCAL BOKAR THIAM: That's
a very good question.
So this is what happens.
Knowledge is very
compartmentalizing.
People will study history
where a professor of history
or a PhD in history, they know
about these empires of Ghana,
of Mali, of Somalia.
They know those.
They know the names.
They know the leaders.
But when it comes to
the general culture,
I can walk in virtually
every classroom in America
and ask a young
African-American kid,
have you ever heard
of these empires
from which you come from?
And the answer would be no.
So we have not
integrated that knowledge
into public education period.
Why?
Because frankly, slavery
is difficult to talk about.
That's why.
But you can talk about that
subject through the music,
because through the music, you
can watch almost any subject.
And through the playing of
an instrument and saying,
OK, we're going to do some
music from the Delta blues.
They could go back and now
listen to these guys from Mali,
they could go back.
And they can seamlessly
find in their own space
the connection to that.
But the actual academic
knowledge exists perfectly.
You go to la Sorbonne they
have all these books about it.
But in history,
they're never applied
what that meant to the
development of a superpower.
Because that's a little tricky.
People who write books
have a certain sense--
particularly in
academia-- of supremacy.
So it's difficult.
It's not an accident
if you look at the way in
which American music functions.
In the literature, the first
person baptized King of Jazz
is a classical musician
who happens to be white,
who is a very
competent musician.
His name is Paul Whiteman.
He's the son of the great
conductor of the Denver
Orchestra.
But he's not a jazz musician.
But he loves the
music, and he's going
to ask a young Jewish
composer to go in Harlem,
listen to the music that
these people are playing.
And he comes back
with a piece that we
call "Rhapsody In Blue".
It's a real piece.
There is not a single
note of improvisation,
and it's not really jazz.
But it's an attempt.
But in the literature today,
he's the Kind of Jazz.
When African-Americans
hear that, they are upset.
That's the generation
of Armstrong.
Because Armstrong
and [INAUDIBLE]
and Freddie Keppard
and others before
have laid out the
performance for that.
They decide to create a new
style that they call swing.
And the father of that music
is an African-American chemist
by the name of
Fletcher Henderson, who
couldn't find a job in
chemistry, played the piano.
And the nation
should be grateful
that he could not find
a job in chemistry.
But when you look at the
way in which he articulated
the instrumentation, which
we call the big band,
if you play big band
music in America,
you play Fletcher Henderson.
Because he's telling you,
OK, this is five trumpet,
this is how they work.
This is four trombone,
This is five saxophone,
these are the rules.
And if you apply my rules,
you'll have a great band.
And if you don't, you
won't have a great band.
And Fletcher Henderson
and Ellington, these guys
are out there doing it.
And the new King of Swing
is Benny Goodman, who
is an absolutely fine musician.
But he's not issued
from that community.
So then young
African-Americans who
were playing in the big
bands were really upset.
And they said now, we're
going to create a music that
is so complex melodically,
so fast technically, that it
is going to require so much
mastery of your instrument,
we want to see if you're
going to be the king of that.
And they called a bebop.
And guess what?
There's no king of bebop, except
the two guys who created it.
And the industry said, we
don't want this music anymore.
We're going to go
toward something that's
less convoluted, and
they turned their sites
to what was a black music
called rhythm and blues.
And they look at what
Buddy Waters is doing,
and Howlin' Wolf, and Chuck
Berry-- who just passed--
and Little Richard--
who's still alive--
and they say, oh, we
can deal with this.
And that's how Elvis
Presley comes in.
His first songs we're
literally Little Richard songs.
So he's the king of that.
So there was this
replication, which
is a function of that friction
that exists between minority
groups who have to create
something when they need
in a majority situation in order
to retain a sense of identity.
And the majority will
look at what they create,
and eventually if they like it,
they're going to take it over.
So as long as you understand
that that's a process,
you can avoid paying
bills to your psychologist
or psychotherapist.
Because it's going
to happen wherever
that context is present.
If you are green in
a purple, and there's
five green for 20 purple,
you're going to have that.
If you have 12
blue for 30 yellow,
you're going to have that.
It doesn't really matter.
These are the natural frictions
of minorities creating art
to get a sense of identity, and
a majority looking at that art
and deciding, yeah, we
like what you're doing,
and we're going to take it.
Soul music.
Soul music was defining the
landscape of American music
between 1970 and '75.
The industry was desperate,
because European Americans
could not work.
And so they went and
recruited three guys out
of Nashville,
Tennessee who really
wanted to do country music.
And they said, no, we
want you to write this.
We're going to call it disco.
We're going to make a movie
called "Saturday Night Fever".
They found the worst
dancer in America.
They put him in the
middle of the dance floor.
I mean, this is a time after
which we've had "Soul Train".
I mean, have you seen those
dancers on "Soul Train"?
Those guys were bad.
They get-- bless his
soul, what's his name?
John Travolta.
You know that guy can't dance.
They put him there,
and the Bee Gees
became for a period of time
this expression of the majority
population playing soul music,
playing the music of Motown,
playing the music
of Marvin Gaye.
And Barry Gibbs, to his credit,
is an amazing songwriter.
But again, this is not
what they wanted to do.
They wanted to
play country music.
The industry said no, we
need you to get into this so
that we can compete.
Because music is an
expression of cultural power.
So the majority is
always going to want
to be represented first.
And so once you understand
that, like I said,
hopefully that save you from
your psychotherapist bill.
But it's not easy.
OK, thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]